Les chevaliers n'ont jamais fléchi, n'ont jamais faibli les exploratats...
Cette carte postale, les enfants, l'Himalaya, n'est-il pas merveilleux qu'elle nous arrive de si loin ?
Merveilleux, merveilleux, c'est normal ça, non ? Il y a la poste !
Normal, normal, avoue, tout semble normal, mais avant qu'on ne l'invente, il n'y avait pas de poste.
Qui est-ce qu'il a inventé, la poste ?
Oh oui, maestro, racontez, maestro !
Eh bien, voyons, dans les temps lointains, c'était les troubadours ou les marchands qui délivraient courrier et colis.
Au hasard de leur pérégrination, quand ce n'était pas les moines ou les bouchers.
À la fin du 15e siècle, l'Europe comptait 100 millions d'habitants.
Le grand bouleversement s'annonce.
Mais la géographie reste balbutiante, secret d'état.
Elle n'est pas enseignée.
Les princes ignorent presque tout des pays qu'ils gouvernent.
Pays que leurs messagers, leurs chevaucheurs se doivent de connaître.
Eh bien, Jean-Baptiste, tu as encore grandi.
François, quelle joie, viens donc.
Un bon repas t'attend.
Je vous vois si rarement, mes enfants. Quel métier que celui de chevaucheur.
Toi à Rome, Jeannot à Venise, Roger, en Autriche...
Nous venons quand nous le pouvons, mère. Le courrier ne peut pas attendre et nous gagnons de l'argent.
Tiens, ceci est pour toi.
Un florin d'or. Je n'en ai pas vu depuis longtemps.
Je dois repartir, mère.
Déjà ?
Hélas, oui, regarde. J'ai un pli du pape pour l'empereur Frédéric d'Autriche.
C'est vrai, c'est le sceau de sa sainte Sté le Pape.
Et c'est adressé à l'Empereur.
Tu vois, c'est important.
Prends un peu de nourriture et une couverture neuve.
Tu auras froid dans les montagnes.
Oui, mère.
Dis, oncle François, je peux venir avec toi ?
Oh, je peux regarder un âne et il marche bien, tu sais.
Pas cette fois, Jean-Baptiste, mais bientôt, je te le promets.
On verra du pays tous les deux, mon garçon.
Attention à toi. Au revoir, mon fils.
Au revoir, à bientôt.
Ne m'oublie pas, reviens vite.
Fais venir vos frères, j'ai des choses importantes à vous dire.
Léonard, écoutez les enfants, l'Europe change.
C'est notre chance.
Nous, l'État-ci, nous pouvons y organiser la distribution de tout le courrier
et devenir très riches.
Et pourquoi elle va changer ?
Oui, toi qui es un peu devin, explique-nous pourquoi elle va changer.
Et comment ?
Fais-vous l'expliquer.
Marie, la fille du duc de Bourgogne, va épouser l'archiduc maximilien.
Leur fils, qui se nommera Philippe le Beau, épousera Jeanne, héritière du trône d'Espagne.
Un grand empire va se former et réunir l'Espagne, l'Allemagne, la Bourgogne et les Pays-Bas.
C'est compliqué, tous ces ducs et ces empereurs.
L'important, c'est que ces gens s'écrivent des lettres, beaucoup de lettres.
Je n'ai pas assez de cavaliers, il faut s'organiser.
Alors, toi, Jeannot, tu feras la route de Venise, Léonard, celle de Milan, toi, François, Bruxelles.
J'ai un homme qui dit qu'il connaît le chemin. Tu vas l'accompagner.
Bruxelles ? Je connais que ça. Allez, suivez-moi.
On arrive à Fussel.
Y'a une bonne auberge !
Mais tiens, tous les frais sont payés, hein !
Pas étonnant que ça coûte si cher d'envoyer une lettre !
Et voilà Ulm !
Y'a là une excellente auberge !
On va bien se régaler !
Souviens plus très bien du chemin qu'on doit prendre !
Et il faut demander aux paysans !
Oh ! Oh !
La route pour Reynhausen, c'est par là ?
Hein ?
Non, non, c'est là !
Faites attention aux brigands !
Mours sous la vie !
Pitié, les brigands tournaient à gauche un peu avant la forêt.
Mais il faut demander.
Et en Pays-Bas ?
Et il parle pas l'allemand.
Hé, Gans, la ville de Gans, c'est bien par là ?
Oh, ville d'empereur Maximilien.
Quoi si longtemps ? Vous avez traîné dans les auberges ?
Non, seigneur, c'est que on a rencontré des bandits et des pluies nous ont retardés.
Et les chevaux étaient bien fatigués.
Grand-père, notre système est trop lent.
Un courrier met 20 jours pour aller de l'Autriche aux Pays-Bas.
et trois semaines des Pays-Bas en Espagne.
Et ils coûtent trop cher.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut y faire, François ?
Les chevaux ne peuvent pas galoper plus vite
et les hommes doivent manger et dormir.
Il faut établir des relais.
Des relais ?
Regardez, en Trinz-Bruckegan, je vois 35 relais.
Environ un, toutes les dix lieues.
Mais tu te rends compte du nombre d'hommes qu'il faudrait employer ?
Nous ne sommes pas assez nombreux et ça nous coûterait encore plus cher.
Mais non, il faut un chevaucheur à chaque relais, un homme du pays.
Il n'aura jamais à aller loin de chez lui
et je parie qu'on pourra faire Innsbrutgang en cinq ou six jours.
Six jours ? Mais tu exagères, ça nous prend plus de deux semaines et encore, quand tout va bien.
Écoutez, on va essayer Jean-Baptiste et moi. Ils montent bien et c'est lire les cartes.
Ton neveu emmène un petit peu jeune.
Ouais, j'ai 15 ans et je serai majeur dès l'année prochaine.
Quelqu'un possède-t-il un bon cheval par ici ?
Ah oui, Gérard le forgeron, c'est la troisième maison par là.
J'ai une proposition à te faire.
Intéressant, je vais bien essayer. Et chaque fois, tu me donneras six sous.
Six sous et même huit s'il fait nuit.
C'est bon, j'ai un cheval rapide. Six sous, ça me va.
Ah, ça me convient.
Vous me demandez si j'ai des chevaux à violiner un peu pour le six sous, je suis d'accord.
Oui, c'est d'accord.
On peut faire l'essai. Tu retournes au premier village et jeudi, quand le soleil est à midi, tu donnes la lettre au forgeron.
Moi, j'attends au dernier relais pour voir ce que ça donne. Tu m'y rejoindras.
Bon, eh bien, j'y vais.
Relais suivant.
Eh, mon cheval.
Eh, où il est mon cheval ?
C'est mon fils qui doit se promener.
Eh, voyons, eh...
Attends, eh, je vais le chercher.
Hans, où es-tu ?
Oh...
Je vais... Maintenant, je finis mon casse-croûte et je pars.
Ah, non ! Ah non, non, non, pour 6 sous, tu fonces au galop et tout de suite.
Ah, bon, bon, d'accord, eh, il était demandé.
J'y vais.
Si, portez au prochain relais. Urgent.
Bon, donne-le. Tiens.
Attends, je finis de la réparer.
Y'a tard ?
Bah tant mieux, ça me fera 8 sous au lieu de 6.
On prend un verre avant de partir, ça va nous remonter un peu.
Partez, on prend Charles.
J'ai pris un petit peu de retard.
Pour 2 sous de plus, hein ?
On se repose ?
Ça fait 2 jours qu'on attend.
Le système de relais, ça ne marche pas.
Si, ça fera 6 sous.
Et voilà votre courrier.
Courrier impérial, chapeau.
À jamais Jean-Baptiste.
Il leur a fallu plus de temps qu'à un seul homme.
Écoute, j'ai une idée.
On va l'essayer.
Tu entends ce cornet au loin, tu te prépares.
Quand le cavalier arrive, tu te tiens prêt.
Il te remet cette bougette et tu pars.
Et tu ne traînes pas en route.
Tu as 10 lieux à parcourir au galop.
Sinon, pas de sous. Compris ?
Oui, chef. Compris, chef.
Je crois que ça va marcher. On fait un lycée ?
D'accord, je vais attendre au dernier relais.
J'y vais.
Avec le système des relais, le courrier poursuit son chemin jour et nuit.
A la vitesse d'un cheval au galop, on bat tous les records.
Tull, avec son cheval, fait le trajet jusqu'à Gant, en 15 jours au minimum.
Et nous, devinez, une semaine.
Cinq jours.
Chaque coursier ne fait qu'une dizaine de lieux.
Il connaît les meilleurs chemins et il ne s'arrête pas dans les auberges.
En quelques années, les frères Tassi vont établir un grand réseau postal.
Voyez, de Innsbruck à Naples, ou de Bruxelles à Madrid.
Anne, ma fille, vous avez de la chance.
Nous avons trouvé un jeune mari, Philippe le Beau, fils de l'empereur Maximilien.
Il est dans les Flandres, une des plus riches provinces du monde.
Vous allez pouvoir vous y rendre avec de beaux cadeaux.
130 vaisseaux, 20 000 hommes d'équipage, 100 valets, 100 000 livres de viande fumée, 150 000 litres de vin, 300 kilos de farine, 500 vaches, 4 taureaux, 3 000...
Faites venir le chef des coursiers.
Majesté.
Enrique, tu vas te rendre en Flandre et départ ton meilleur cavalier et abri d'abattu pour avertir Philippe de l'arrivée de Jeanne afin qu'il puisse la recevoir comme il convient.
Oui, majesté.
Roi ! Roi !
Oui, chef.
Prends ton meilleur cheval. Tu files avec moi en Flandre.
Bon, les Pays-Bas, il faut traverser l'Espagne, les Pyrénées, la France.
Oh, c'est la galère.
Eh oui, c'est fatiguant.
Et si on prenait le bateau ?
Le capitaine est un ami. Allez, on y va.
La flottille va essuyer une lourde tremble.
Et le voyage va durer plus de deux mois.
Comme ça.
Nous arrivons à Midelbourg, aux Pays-Bas.
Mais Philippe le beau, que sa fiancée, la princesse Jeanne, arrive demain.
Mais pourquoi tu ne nous as pas prévenus plus tôt ?
Le prince Philippe est chez son père en Autriche.
C'est que le voyage était un périple difficile.
Les chevaux étaient fatigués.
Il y a eu des bandits.
Les montagnes.
Vous êtes des bohariens, des moins que rien, des fainéants.
Et vous allez être punis.
Jeanne vous attend dans la ville de Lière.
Prenons le chemin, vite.
J'ai prévu pour vous.
Princesse.
Mes majestés, le protocole, l'étiquette, le règlement.
Vous allez nous marier, padre.
Oui.
Mais où et quand ?
Mais ici et maintenant ?
Je vous déclare époux et femme, unis devant le Seigneur.
Pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Non mais attendez, je n'ai pas fini.
Les épouses doivent mutuellement fidélité.
Bravo, cousin.
On va faire libérer ces deux-là.
Vincent, il n'est Charles, fils de Philippe et de Jeanne de Castille.
Réjouissons-nous.
Urgentissime, courez annoncer la nouvelle à l'empereur.
Des postes vers Innsbruck, express.
Un petit-fils, Charles, il règnera sur toute l'Europe.
Tiens, pour la bonne nouvelle.
Mes chers amis, j'ai besoin d'un courrier régulier avec l'Espagne où je vais régner.
Il devra passer par Paris et Blois, où réside le roi de France, qui est d'accord.
Mais les courriers espagnols risquent de vous faire des ennuis.
La France est derrière nous.
Devant nous, l'Espagne est bientôt Pamplune.
Philippe arrive. Ils viennent organiser leur relais de poste.
Ils vont nous voler nos clients.
Nous ruiner.
Il faut les arrêter.
Oui, et à tout prix. Je sais ce qu'il faut faire.
C'est la fête à Pampune. Tu vas voir Henrique.
Chambre, homergiste.
Pour que vous puissiez acheminer la poste en Espagne.
Mais seigneur, vous avez déjà vos courriers. Nous vous servons finalement depuis des années.
Nous, c'est pour les postes internationales.
Aussi, on peut le faire, sire.
Nous ne voulons enfoncer ni nos fidèles serviteurs, ni nos amis étrangers.
J'ai un peu urgent pour ma fille Jeanne en Flandre.
Chambelant, faites-moi une copie.
Celui qui remettra la lettre le premier obtiendra pas tant.
C'est bon.
C'est le retard, il a même pas franchi la ligne d'arrivée, il l'a franchi.
Attendez la réponse, la voici.
Majesté, voici la réponse à votre missive.
Toi ?
Pense majesté que mon chevaucheur n'est pas loin.
Apporte-t-il une réponse ?
Sûrement majesté, sûrement.
Bravo les tassies, vous garantissez les délais ?
Tolède, Bruxelles, 12 jours en été, 14 en hiver.
Tu en es sûr ?
Délai garanti majesté, sur mes biens et mon corps.
Bon, chambelan, faites lettre de patente pour que les Tassis acheminent la poste en nos provinces de Castille et d'Aragon.
Par la grâce de l'empereur Maximilien, les membres de la famille Tassi ici présente sont élevés au rang de père de l'Empire.
Leurs armes familiales seront agrémentées de l'agre impérial, de plumes de paon et d'un lambrequin d'azur et d'argent.
Nous abordons le XVIe siècle et le monde change. Le progrès avance, Gutenberg et l'imprimerie sont déjà là, Christophe Colomb a découvert l'Amérique, la Renaissance s'annonce.
Bientôt Charles Quint va régner, et avec lui l'Empire des Tassies va encore s'étendre.
Et les Tassies deviendront barons, comtes et même princes.
En 1867, le prince de Tourne et Taxi va céder ses relais de diligence, chevaux et bureaux de poste à la Prusse.
Moyennant confortable contrepartie.
Depuis, vous connaissez.